let's say that you're curious about
people's TV watching habits in
particular how much TV do people in the
country watch so what you are concerned
with if we imagine the entire country
and we've already talked about it
especially we're talking about a country
like the United States but pretty much
any country is a very large population
in the United States we're talking about
on the order of 300 million people so
ideally if you could somehow magically
do it you would survey or somehow
observe all 300 million people and take
the mean of how much hour how many hours
of TV they watch on a given day and then
that will give you that will give you
the parameter the population mean but
we've already talked about in a case
like this that's very impractical even
if you went tried to do it by the time
you did it your data might be stale
because some people might have passed
away other people might have been born
who knows what might have happened and
so this is this is a truth that is out
there this is this is there is a
theoretical population mean for the
amount of the the average or the mean
hours of TV watched per day by Americans
there is a truth here at any given point
in time it's just pretty much impossible
to come up with the exact answer to come
up with this exact truth but you don't
give up you say well well maybe I don't
have to survey all 300 million or
observe all 300 million instead I'm just
going to observe a sample I'm just going
to observe a sample right over here and
let's say for the sake make the
computation simple you do a sample of 6
and we'll talk about later why 6 might
not be as large of a sample as you would
like but you survey how much TV
these folks watch and you get that they
you find one person who watched one and
a half hours another person watched two
and a half hours another person watched
four hours and then you get one person
who watched two hours and then you get
two people who watched one hour each
so given this data from your sample what
do you get as your sample mean well the
sample mean which we would denote by
lower
case X with a bar over it it's just the
sum of all of these divided by the
number of data points we have so let's
see we have one point five plus two
point five plus four plus two plus one
plus one and all of that divided by six
which gives let's see the numerator one
point five plus two point five is 4 plus
4 is 8 plus 2 is 10 plus 2 more is 12 so
this is going to be 12 over 6 which is
equal to 2 hours of television so at
least for your sample you say my sample
mean is 2 hours of television it's a
it's an estimate it's a statistic that
is trying to estimate this parameter
this thing that's very hard to know but
it's our best shot maybe we'll get a
better answer if we get more data points
but this is what we have so far now the
next question you ask yourself is well I
don't want to just estimate my
population mean I also I also want to
estimate another parameter I also am
interested in estimating my population
variance so once again since we can't
survey everyone in the population this
is much this is pretty much impossible
to know but we're going to attempt to
estimate this parameter we have tempted
to estimate the mean now we will also
attempt to estimate this parameter this
variance parameter so how would you do
it
well reasonable logic would say well we
maybe will do the same thing that the
sample as we would have done with the
population when you're doing the
population variance you would take each
point each data point in the population
find the distance between that and the
normal the the population mean take the
square of that difference and then add
up all those squares of those difference
and then divide by the number of data
points you have so let's try that over
here so let's try to find take each of
these data points take each of these
data points and find the difference let
me do that in a different color
each of these data points and find the
difference between that data point the
difference between that data point and
our sample mean not the population we
don't know what the population mean the
sample mean so that's that first data
point plus the second data point plus
the second data point so it's 4
are minus 2 squared plus 1 minus 2
squared and this is what you would have
done if you're taking a population
variance if this was your entire
population this is how you would you
would find a population mean here if
this was your entire population and you
would find the squared distances from
each of those data points and then
divide by the number of data points so
let's just think about this a little bit
1 minus 2 squared then you have 2.5
minus 2 squared 2 point 5 minus 2 2
being the sample mean squared plus let
me see this green color plus 2 plus 2
minus 2 squared plus plus 1 minus 2
squared and then maybe you would divide
by the number of data points that you
have where you have the number of data
points so in this case we're dividing by
6 and what would we get in this
circumstance well if we just do the
computation 1.5 minus 2 is negative 0.5
we square that this becomes a positive
0.25 4 minus 2 squared is going to be
that's going to be 2 squared which is 4
1 minus 2 squared well that's negative 1
squared which is just 1 2 point 5 minus
2 is 0.5 squared is 0.25 2 minus 2
squared well this is 0 and then 1 minus
2 squared is is 1 it's negative 1
squared so we just get 1 just good 1 and
if we add all of this up let's see we
get a let me add the whole numbers first
4 plus 1 is 5 plus 1 is 6 and then we
have 2.25
so this is going to be equal to 6.5 let
me write this in a neutral color so this
is going to be 6.5 over over this 6
right over here and we could write this
as well there's a couple of ways that we
could write this but I'll just get the
calculator out and we can just calculate
it so 6.5 6.5 divided by 6 gets us if we
round it's approximately one point zero
eight
so it's approximately 1.08 is is this
calculation now what we have to think
about is whether this is the best
calculation whether this is the best
estimate for for the population variance
given the data that we have you can
always argue that we could have more
data but given the data we have is this
the best calculation that we can make to
estimate the population variance and
I'll have you think about that for a
second well it turns out that this is
close this is close to the best
calculation the best estimate that we
can make given the data we have and
sometimes this will be called the sample
variance but it's a particular type of
sample variance where we just divide by
the number of data points we have and so
people will write just an n over here so
this is one way to define a sample
variance in an attempt to estimate our
population variance but it turns out and
in the next video I'll give them give
you an intuitive explanation of why it
turns out this way and then I would also
like to write a computer simulation that
at least experimentally makes you feel a
little bit better but it turns out
you're going to get a better estimate
and it's a little bit weird and voodoo
ish at first when you first think about
it you're going to get a better estimate
for your population variance for your
population variance if you don't divide
by 6 if you don't divide by the number
of data points you have
but you divide by one less than the
number of data points you have so how
would we do that and we can denote that
as sample variance so when most people
talk about the sample variance they're
talking about the sample variance where
you do this calculation but instead of
dividing by 6 you were to divide by 5
you were to divide by 5 so they'd say
you divide by n minus 1
so what would we get in those
circumstances well the top part is going
to be the exact same thing we're going
to get 6.5 we're going to get 6.5 but
then our denominator we have our n is 6
we have six data points we're going to
divide by one less one less than 6 so
we're going to divide by five and six
point five divided by five is equal to
one point three so when we when we
calculate our sample variance
this technique which is the more
mainstream technique and I know it seems
voodoo why are we dividing by n minus 1
wherefore population variance we divide
by n but remember we're trying to
estimate the population variance and it
turns out that this is a better estimate
because this this calculation is under
estimating what the popular the
population variance is this is a better
estimate we don't know for sure what it
is these both could be way off it could
be just by chance what we happen to
sample but over over many samples and
there's many ways to think about it this
is going to be a better calculation it's
going to give you a better estimate and
so how would we write this down how
would we write this down
with mathematical notation well we could
remember we're taking the sum the sum
and we're taking each of the data points
so we'll start with the first data point
all the way to the nth data point this
lowercase n says that hey we're taking
we're looking at the sample if I just an
uppercase n that usually denotes that
we're trying to sum up everything in the
population here we're looking at a
sample of size lowercase n now we're
taking each data point so each X sub I
and from it we're subtracting we're
subtracting the sample mean we're
subtracting the sample mean and then
we're squaring it we're taking the sum
of the squared distances and then we're
dividing not by the number of data
points we have but by one less than the
number of data points we have so this
calculation where we summed up all of
this and then we've divided by five not
by 6 this is the standard definition of
sample of sample variance so I'll leave
you there in the next video I will
attempt to give you an intuition of why
we are dividing by n minus 1 instead of
dividing by n